I am against book bands for a number of
different reasons number one they are
taking teachers out of the decisions as
to what materials are appropriate for
children of what age and putting it in
the hands of parents parents whose
expertise is not education whose
expertise is not literature whose
expertise is not a child development so
we're saying let's give people who are
less qualified the ability to decide
what is in school libraries they silence
authors they silence Librarians they
they damage the trust and the dialogue
between schools and communities and also
they can have the very corrosive effect
of tying schools up not only in protests
but in legal challenges that's not good
for anybody that's not good for learning
as a progressive right I'm a progressive
I'm not for censorship